foreign
happy Thursday everyone a little bit of
a change of pace today so Rachel is
um
on vacation how dare her but I'm
stepping in to at least try to be a host
for the hangout
welcome to the data science hangout if
this is the first time that you're
joining welcome uh we're super glad that
you're here if you're returning which I
suspect a lot of you are welcome back
love that as a reminder this is a casual
conversation uh and a casual environment
so if you're here and you have thoughts
we want to hear from you no matter how
much experience you have or don't have
um this the space in this hour is really
for you
um so with all that said uh I want to
introduce our leader or featured leader
for the day Matthew Montero super glad
that you're here uh maybe introduce
yourself and tell us what's going on
yeah oh uh yes thank you so my name is
Matthew Montero I had Enterprise data
services within jinery on the I.T side
actually so it might be a little bit
different
um where we actually provide services
for the business so
um well whether that may be database
services or data Lake Services
um data science Services which I think a
lot of you guys will be interested in
data reporting services
and then with that it's all about is
provide the uh let's provide systems and
applications that are hard-earned by it
but then also in a self-service way as
well submitting that here is a platform
that business can build on or improve on
and and we support to make sure that
they'll stay up and running
um my background actually is Actuarial
um of about 12 12 years back graduated
college
um was gun hold of being an actuary
doing all those exams
um I landed into a job where I got to do
both both Actuarial work but then we got
a little flavor analytics and from then
that grew to overseeing a team building
a team from ground up and overseeing a
team eventually I had a as all time in
Pharmaceuticals which I also was
building a analytical team to solve the
clinical trial automation challenge but
then from there I moved on to here to
eventually leading a whole data
organization according to the CTO
a little background
wonderful and we're thrilled to have you
if you're just joining in
um
I said it once but I'll say it again I'm
stepping in for Rachel this week she's
taking a vacation doing my best
um there are a few ways to participate
we want to hear from all of you so you
can uh keep your camera off put your
camera on keep yourself on mute take
yourself off commute you can submit
questions or comments via the zoom chat
or you can use a slido which is an
anonymous link so you can ask questions
anonymously and feel free to hop into
the conversation and ask anything that
might be on your mind that you're
curious about Matthew we usually start
with a few standard things Matthew I'm I
looked at your background it's quite
impressive uh and interesting you've
gone from what I think is sort of an
individual contributor role to a quite a
senior leadership oriented role I was
wondering if you could share a little
bit about that Journey with everyone
yeah so even from the beginning I was
always interested in data and also the
process on to engineer that data to
actually get some insights from it so
being an actor is always very analytical
and trying to solve that so that's what
my individual contributor I built some
applications or let me try to find ways
to simplify that process
um or at least automate the process uh
from there but then when I was maybe a
five six years into the into that space
I was like well I want to start leading
teams I want to start building uh
working with other than Mentor Elders to
start be able to do that uh so that's
when I started becoming more of a um a
team lead or technical lead
um but once I got into Pharmaceuticals
um uh it was very different because the
company was a lot bigger uh and and then
I I had a pleasure to having a manager
who was very focused on vision
and so that's when I really got the feel
for like once you have a vision and you
can sell that Vision
um then then then you have the ability
to build as big as a team you want or
need and be able to back that up with
some uh either ways to improve the
business or ways to even improve the
organization as a whole so with that
knowledge I gained through that or
experience of dealing with getting
assaulted or getting new new hires and
coming and defining more strategy for
that Vision uh moved on to the current
company I'm with Jen Reed and it kind of
fostered from there that
um let me take this Vision let me Define
a little further the way I feel it
should be at this company and then let
me build a full strategy around that let
me figure out from day one we get the
data and all the way to
um building applications that use that
data or the self-service route of other
people want to use that data for
um for their analytical purposes
let me fill that strategy around there
and so
um being able to both build that
strategy
um and communicate that to Executives to
different uh to different uh business
units that has the different business
units um it kind of moved me up um
higher relatively fast uh in a sense but
it's being very confident in that vision
and being in the strategy and even the
principles around that as well
and could you clarify what you mean by
by Vision yes so so if you take a step
back and you think of the data you have
um and think of all all the data
processes going back and forth like
where how's that actually going to work
like in a sense of
um data ingestion do you do you want to
platform there do or do you think that
it should just land to some folder
um
um do you do you feel that everything
should be in the database or do you
think something should be in a data like
um so once you get a data into that now
now what happens to it well where does
the data processing happen because the
business unit themselves are going to be
doing all that or do you want to should
it be centralized
um and then from that point now you have
the data process now now what do you do
with it do you just create some can
reports and be able to have that
executive Studio see that or do you go
to other stream and Italian business now
take that data and do other stuff with
it create their own report okay the only
analytics analysis
then you gotta take a step even further
back of well
um what about uh what is in a global
company do you have to do this all at a
central location or do you have to split
this up into a regional locations so
it's really laying out the whole piece
the whole Vision how everything is going
to be you know you didn't go into the
technical Seattle
what it all looks like and that's the
first thing you got to sell and because
at least you have a vision you have
something you can communicate to
everyone
uh and then that's when you kind of
break down now what's that strategy to
accomplish that Vision because you can't
do all that one day it's going to take
some time so you have to have
individuals
um steps or strategies to accomplish
that
and I'm I'm more so uh personally
curious but again everyone you can uh
put your own questions in the zoom chat
and also in the slido and we'll
prioritize those but at sort of what
level of your career do you think it's
start it's appropriate to start thinking
about
um visions and and at that sort of level
of abstraction
yeah so it got to where
um so at a time when I was
um a little bit earlier it got to a
point when I was leading a team and I
was asked to how are you how are you
going to
you you know my vision so my boss at the
time you know my vision how I am how are
you going to make that Vision happen
once I was given that when I can sit
down and ask you really think through
that
um that's when the moment expected my
head like this is this is my next step
this is what I want to be able to do is
both to find that Vision to Define that
high level strategies to do it and then
and work with teams to actually make
that happen and Now's the Time actually
where they clicked on me and said I was
thinking about it a couple years back
Great And for those who might be
unfamiliar with genre or sort of uh
exactly what you do could you give a
little background there generally your
role in it where you fit in
yeah so generally is a general insurance
company uh we're a global company
um we uh we work we build the insurance
policies directly
um and direct insurance and I oversee
the data department so
um so I report the CTO who's uh who
obviously the whole it Department my job
is to oversee anything regarding data so
what we can think of databases data
Lakes data reporting data science so
anything with MIT perspective
um um I I oversee that I create the
processes around there or received
classes around there each of those
verticals would have their own managers
in there that will take the overall
Vision or strategy and and see it
through
um
yeah so some of the pieces is just
keeping lights on so meaning meaning uh
if there's a database up and running
maybe we can think of a shell like
here's a database
um business units they can use it the
way they want it but we'll just make
sure that stays up and running if it
goes off well we'll make sure that or it
dies we'll make sure that we get a back
cover running as soon as we can or if
say
um uh or if you're doing some
um data recovery or whatnot we can we
will always do that as well
great and there is a question uh from
Brittany in the chat I just want to make
sure that um we're super clear on
someone who's the head of let's say data
science first I think your title is data
services is is there a difference uh
could you just clarify
yeah so
um if you think of someone who's going
to bring that service up and running so
I think our studio probably a good
example so
um one of the things I um right there
when I first started was like let's put
our Studio Pro into the into our
ecosystem and so let's bring that um
let's get all the IT team all together
um let's get all the uh to be like an
infrastructure and we had to get all the
pieces so once you get then you didn't
get installed and get it up and running
so that is the self-servers or
enablement that my area do so that's the
services we provide is bringing that up
and running and like providing it for
the business students to use a data
science from the business side now use
app service use that platform and build
data sometimes related products might be
in office machine learning or whatnot so
it's kind of like we build it they will
come and use it and if they want more
features or they want changes to it then
they work with us we actually make those
changes happen
great and uh Brittany I see that you
have a question in the chat if uh you
wouldn't mind you want to hop in and ask
that
so just listening to you kind of in your
career progressions
um I'm at you know selfishly at the
point in my career now where I'm
thinking what is next
um and I'm trying to think through like
what does that look like how do like as
an analyst what are the next steps what
are the possible next things that I
could do
um I have some ideas but I really don't
know like how to set those sort of
I'll call them like my five-year
three-year types of career goals um do
you have any advice for
um people in that kind of individual
contributor role as they're trying to
think through how do I set a path for
where I may end up in the next like
handful of years or so yeah so uh great
question
um
so the way I always looked I always
think it was like basically four
different uh phases for someone in in
Tech as you do
um your analysts move to an engineer and
I'll talk about these one second you go
to engineer you go to architect and do
Webster principle as an analyst you come
in and into you guys going into
different projects and you're just
trying to understand high level what is
actually going on right dig into some
details and try to know where to where
uh where things are flowing
um so you might not really know how to
come up with a solution but at least you
know what the problem is and you might
be able to pinpoint of where maybe a
searching can fit the next stage is
engineering now now I now I know that
now I don't know the problem now I need
to actually start coding and starting to
solve that and so an engineer will
actually write the code or work with
people to write the code to uh to solve
the problem and this might be a small
problem obviously a large problem but in
general they're just cultures to get
this get it done
the next step is the architect the
architect is someone who now does would
design that solution right so before an
engineer would come and solve it well an
architect might have a high level view
of how to solve it so it might be a
hotfix and to a similar point then you
might just do a whole Band-Aid or it
might be a whole architecture change
that hasn't happened uh maybe moving on
from
um having the code embedded in there
versus having API instead so it might be
a whole architectural change depending
on what the extent of the of the
challenge
then you have a principal who kind of
knows all those different pieces but is
able to
um able to work with other Architects
and try to train them on these all
different things we could have done or
these are different we could do uh so
maybe talk about hot broad in a broad
way of all the different solutions you
could do or uh for the possibilities or
even try things together and stuff so
it's very much of that career projection
of learning new things along the way
um and I think and I and so myself as a
coder let me talk a little bit about
this earlier but I started about just an
R programmer and I built applications um
from from the ground up and I've got
even I got more and more broad as I was
testing more and more systems so meaning
I got in the beginning I was just
touching R and then start reaching out
to latex and then start reaching out to
well now I need to work with databases
so let me learn um given that as a base
database up and running let me start
filling it up with data and like maybe
create a application process which
interacts the data then this is when and
then it gets even bigger and bigger and
bigger and then through that experience
this is how you kind of Move Along on
that Journey from an engineer to an
architect to a principal
uh so I I always feel that the best
um leaders in the tech side
um or an I.T side come from engineer
backgrounds because they know what it's
like to be in the Louisa thing being
able to solve problems and also being
Architects because they also have a
higher view of what the solution could
be that means they can talk to other
Architects or other people with
Solutions and kind of have a possible
view how it works they might not know
all the kind of details at that point in
time because they're no longer in the
width of it but they have a the
experience of seeing different solutions
because in general obviously yeah you
might have different flavors or words
being used to have engine at all similar
enough
thank you
hopefully that helps give me a follow-up
question
is that good Brittany
yeah I think maybe one quick follow-up
question is
um I know at least for me I definitely
love that individual contributor role
but I don't have necessarily an interest
in
like the leadership
um particularly like maybe the HR
aspects of leadership and those kinds of
things
um so do you like how do you suggest
people who have that interest in
individual contributor and even like the
mentoring of other individual
contributors but who don't want the like
HR types responsibilities of like team
leadership how do you see that playing
into sort of how you plan out or think
about your career progression yeah so
there's there's like
um like two routes you can go you can go
continue that principal route which
you're like individual contributor
knowledge very much of that
um that's also another flavor is a tech
lead of that meaning that you will
oversee other people without like but
you're not directly a manager like
um which is uh which is I did um earlier
on in my career I oversaw a lot of
different programmers
um and I was while they weren't on my
direct reports I I assigned to work I I
did all that so everything but the HR
stuff
um and then of course you go to other
routes which you get a little more
disconnected from some of their work but
yeah you go to the people manager and
then manager or manager's type of role
um but yeah it's I think you'll look
more for like tech leads or leads of
blah blah and that's generally what
you'll be seeing um if you see titles
such as heads of or
um or a manager or directors and stuff
that's more of people type of related
roles
awesome thank you
pressing on that a bit Matthew so
looking back I'm I'm curious
what are indicators of opportunities
um
that
sort of uh speak to you or would speak
to someone like uh that ones is clearly
um that indicate that like this is
a project or an opportunity where I'm
going to move from sort of one stage of
my career
to another
um or I'm going to become more senior
and like what should people look for if
that's what they desire
yeah so
when I wanted to or when someone wants
to like take more of that management
role then it depends on the company but
what I what could happen is you start
asking for Consultants or you start
bringing consultants and start mentoring
them to solve whatever problem is and
once the therapists are seeing uh your
managers are start seeing that or you're
doing very well with doing um the
interpersonal relationship and all that
then that can help identify that you're
ready and of course communication with
your manager is the key I've always been
very close with my managers to make sure
that I've known what what are my goals
what what do I plan to do what do I want
to do in the future and what can I do to
demonstrate that I have that ability or
or what are the things I should improve
on to so that I'm ready for that or will
be ready for that
um but then the other thing is also
being very
[Music]
um
the communication ability is also key
um when I was way in the beginning I
wasn't good at presentations I wasn't
good at
um speaking in front of a large amount
of people wasn't
um I was very shy and I can go very
technical really fast and I just didn't
know how to slow down and make sure that
not or be kind of says that not everyone
understands
uh the tech as well so I had to change
the way I'm using the wording and so
once I once uh I did a lot of soft skill
um
um um growth in that so I did a lot of
different classes and whatnot and so
once you once you start learning those
skill sets that actually helps you to
move on to move on higher because
it is what I find is not really the
beauty of that coding work and all of
that that really the managers see it's
your communication on how to present
that and show why what uh and just and
describe and word and why what the
difficult challenge or what benefit does
this challenge does Challenge and
solving this challenge give and if that
actually gets noticed it's not
unfortunately enough to work behind a
scene so like for example you build a
giant application they can do so many
different things
they don't see those tens of thousands
of lines of code
um a friend of those possible lives in
the code all they see is the app itself
so then that is your key selling point
is what is an app that's useful there
what is Elegance there
um because if you talk about the code
they're not going to be that interested
very good I'm switching over to the uh
slido questions and uh one question is
can you talk about any challenges you
faced in setting up the systems
environments for data science leaders
and in working with them to get what
they wanted
yes so uh the biggest challenge
um was
at least in the beginning so a little
while back when like animal makes the
data science was kind of new and so
you're trying to bring in platforms that
um no one knew how to do or install
because it's new but then two is
um no one is a culture change of
allowing people to design out having
access to staff and so I'm building
products and the
um on the business side and so that was
one of the biggest challenges was just
changing the culture
um and then in addition to that when it
comes to the technical side is now now
it no longer of having an application
connect to one thing you want to have an
on vacation that can just in general
connect to anything
um and so that's also a little shift of
how the things work so
um at the time I was in business we had
to come up with our own test cases to
run through all the database connections
or
um or run other jobs to make sure things
work and where
into the company was by doing that
because otherwise then it becomes a full
IP owner-owned project and all that and
just it's a little different uh so
nowadays I think I think
um companies are getting or I.T
departments are getting much more open
to
um these analytic systems but I think
but back then it was a little more
challenging
yeah I'll press a little bit I think
there might be a perception that um it
is difficult to work through or work
with curious your thoughts on on that
perception and what you would say
so it was a lot of eye-opening but uh
for me when I'm moving from business to
RT and
um I learned or learned and appreciate a
lot more of what why it's still recall
and there's a lot of things we don't
think about when uh we're on the
business side or maybe we do but how
much work it actually takes and we don't
think of that like for example
um
when we when you say let's bring a
platform into our studio
art R Studio into
um into the environment
um we can just make a request like that
and then hopefully one day someone will
bring in it uh RIT we're bringing in but
then let's take a step back to what IP
does for that well I.T would first need
to do a full review of um of that
product is it will it open up to
security concerns that data data loss
um who where are we what are the
inflation attacks need to be so meaning
like doing EVMS how big a VMS do we need
how big of a use case do people have
what about other use cases that are
going to be leveraging this uh for
example whatever you want to use
um
um a tensorflow or um you know it's not
a modeling uh software so that's an
extension to that uh application
um what about communication like uh you
have RC to connect so how do who's going
to actually monitor that and we're going
to bring it up and running and then
something else is going to oversee it
um what about actual support of these
things the keyboard up and running makes
so if a ticket comes like you can't
access our studio who's going to support
that so we need to make sure it's a
support team actually uh in line for
that
um what is the slas I mean what is the
third level agreement like meaning that
if I'm making a requests to have access
to
um the the service well how long should
it take for uh for that to be actually
done
um uh and then who actually is going to
fulfill those is it is it the data side
is the security side is it like you got
to determine all that
um what about the whole architecture
like um if you're a global company well
you need to think about do I need
Regional setups or do I need just one
giant one what about all the databases I
connect to yeah they consider the data
privacy they look at liberalization so
like uh yeah and what about a failover
so meaning that if something if your
whole I.T Center just turned off
how how do you make sure everything
comes back on and running they're
running somewhere else With Disaster
Recovery
um all those things need to be thought
about all those things can be considered
and so that the appreciation of that
happened when I moved over and like I
gave questions now all the time when I'm
coming I'm putting in new systems like
oh there's we have to think about all
these different different items in order
to even get started with it
foreign
there is anonymous question I'd be
curious if you'd be willing to share a
great example of how your team has had a
big impact also our actuaries as fun and
exciting as they say
uh yeah so
um I'm talking about during my actuary
days so one of the there's a couple of
products that we brought up and one of
them was dealing with data validation
and so when that so this is one of the
first big applications that using
Chinese to do and
the cop is accomplishment came from the
fact that this was business created
business driven
um this is a very different shift from
the old days where um the I.T side would
build applications build those things
from scratch instead business build it
and not only did we build it but we had
test cases we had uh we used code we
used databases we uh we had staging we
had Dev staging improv like we have all
those different things that that a
general a general it team would have and
it was just a big accomplishment we'd
probably roll that out made available
because now it is on the web page and
people can access it without needed no
code and so that was probably the
biggest
um by opening
um for that
and yes actuaries we uh we are not so
um I think that um idea of actually is
being very
um
um uh introverted and what that is at
least the ones I know are very outgoing
and um very
passionate about the numbers and about
the statistics and and the work they do
so
um
either maybe that's made up a new
generation actually coming out
a little more on that there's a hybrid
Anonymous uh not anonymous question uh
submitted by Sam through slido I'm a
statistician slash data scientist who
has to work with many actuaries how are
data science and Actuarial science
different or similar
yeah so uh for maybe a data science
um person or data scientist
um it should be able to jump into be any
any domain and be kind of and all they
need to know is where the data what is
the data show me the data dictionary let
me what are the type insight you're
trying to get out of there and maybe I'm
saying the business process and
actuaries kind of know the whole domain
so it might be if there's an actuary
slash data scientist would I think would
have a little Edge in a sense of they
understand that the technical oh sorry
the methodologically find it all and can
give Insight on how to actually build
analysis around that without that
um a data scientist might be a little
bit uh lost and that's why they had to
work closely with business to do that so
it's kind of like that
um
either you start from scratch don't know
much but you can learn quickly and find
the right people to do it or you're
someone who as an actuary saying a
scientist can
um
uh how enough to get good start and run
with it
very good also Anonymous uh what new
processes have you brought to jenry how
big of an impact I guess we can append
that uh what impact are you hoping to
make in the next one year five years
uh I can't get too much into that
[Music]
um
um but I will say that under
understanding uh the power of data is a
a uh is is what I'm targeting on
by the way I can't really divulge more
understood no problem
um
let's see if you can share what tools
does genre use for a catastrophe
modeling
that's a little Pacific for me as we
just provided services
for users to have that tool
so
gotcha
and then another anonymous question what
kinds of things work for you in changing
the culture in your organization
I think
um getting the rights right Personnel in
place
um so
um finding people that are passionate
about data science or whatever topic it
is and and being expert in that in both
the engineering level like I was saying
earlier but also as a leadership level I
think that's a way to make things change
because in a day people want to want to
hear things from the experts and people
who have had a lot of experience doing
that both from leadership and from the
actually doing the work
you know I I had a question that I
thought of which is as you've progressed
in your career is there any sort of
discomfort uh around like
pulling away from the actual pools and
in the weeds and building applications
oh yes yes so uh it's like I I'm trying
to stop myself from jumping into
projects and start running code
um and it's more because
um I need to be I want to be able to
more Mentor others to be able to do that
into the different wireframes I build or
or oversee or the methodologies that
I've done
um
um I also like I I I have spent more
time on strategy and more of those type
of higher level questions and
discussions and so I I would like to dig
in I still write um our marathon books
um internally I still write
um little applets or small small pieces
of code if something's really
challenging
um but yeah I haven't really coded I
want to say for a couple years now and
um do miss a little bit
um but and I always have my fun once in
a while when I um I come from the all
day so base R was my uh my background so
um I can write based our
um very very uh um thoroughly so it's
always fun when um some of the new
people like were like come up with a
tidy verse and all that and do that and
like this is the way to do it it's the
only way to do it and it's a little fun
to be like okay you can do it this way
and let's do a little benchmarking and
I'll show you some differences you can
do
um so it's always a little fun when you
have like the old timer trying to show
that there's people like there there's
there is some stock in the old knowledge
and when you're mentoring or managing
people
how do you
how do you balance um sort of giving
direction or like saying you know this
is what I would do or like hop in and
actually do that like how do you
determine that line
kind of I I guess
it's so blurred that I don't know I as a
as a manager
um
manager managers I
my job is to make sure that the overall
direction the uh the vertical is going
is is it continues the right path so
that's basically how far I go with the
management of managers
um I try to
um make sure that
we have a shared Vision or shared idea
of where where we're going to go the
next year the next five years
um so it's very much of that when it
comes to the mentoring part it depends
on what vertical we're focusing on
um because I I I I I have a lot of
um trust in a lot of faith in each of
these verticals and so I I let them
Drive whereas and go as long as it
follows that Vision or follows our path
and I'll let them escalate things to me
where things are either got a little
bump in the road and need some course
correction or
um or any additional resources or
whatnot so
um
yeah it's very much
thank you there's a question from Alan
in the chat Alan if you want to ask it
uh
welcome
hi sure yeah often I'm curious about a
little bit more detail Matthew about
your move into I.T and if there were
things that you found to be particularly
effective in streamlining some of those
I.T process requirements resourcing
sustainment
um you know implementation etc those are
familiar dilemmas for us as well
um and I'm used to seeing folks I think
come from I teach a business and then we
have to realize how do we ask things
having just left that function
um so I'm curious that there are
specific things that you feel made that
successful
um and if you also had to negotiate
being sort of in in you know
um being constrained by conflicting
priorities within I.T
um and just you know what that
um what helped there or what or what
hindered you there
yes
um let me see where I try to answer all
those questions
um I might not remember them all
um
I think that
um I I think the big thing is
um coming from a business side moving on
to an I.T
um
and coming from a
um a coding background or like a
technical background is that I have a
have a flavor of both the way to
communicate or to to change the language
from a technical language into a
business language because I've been in
business I can talk Oxford I can talk um
statistics
um
helps a lot so be having someone to be
able to do that translation helps with
the communication with business because
if you don't have that things get lost
in between
um um
you don't want to get to a point when
um you're over complicating it with
technical knowledge because sometimes it
doesn't care about that part they care
about what is after being delivered
um and then from the I.T side I also
would need um need to be able to
um come up with actual technical
requirement or a title needs
um that I need to get from the I.T side
so maybe with infrastructure I mean with
some security which are technically
inclined
um and so I need to make sure I can also
talk in that language so it's very much
of the uh being someone who can do both
of those Communications so an
interpreter as well as someone who can
have the direction of where they want to
go with it all but have that being able
to be interpreted at the same time is I
would say very beneficial
I think I've had all the hits and
everything but Helen feel free yeah
I think being able to sort of speak the
kind of language in each of those
domains is really important um to dig in
a tiny bit more like did you have to uh
did you have to compete for limited it
resources and were there things that
made that
um particularly effective
uh I want to say compete
um it's more of
um
um
convincing on the priority of different
projects so as long as there's alignment
along along the Senior Management fit
alignment of these are the projects that
are going on and these are the ones are
getting prioritize and if there's a
resource need there then that's kind of
like where that discussion is happening
um so as long as there's alignment and
not discussions are happening then it's
fine
um so I want to
um I wouldn't really say competing with
us more of but yeah some kind of um a
overall understanding across the I.T
area
yeah makes sense thank you appreciate
that
there's an anonymous question that asks
what advice would you give someone
managing a data science team and I think
we can just apply it more broadly a team
for the first time
um having a lot of check-ins in the
beginning
um so uh so there's a lot of different
approaches that I've tried a couple of
them uh is during the stand up so
meaning that having those five minutes
10 minutes
um call for the whole team figure out
what other what all the other terms is
this Lavi also have some interpersonal
pieces to there but then also having
those 101s too like so each of my direct
reports I have a one-on-one with them
every every week
um for an hour and that's just to talk
about random stuff it could be probably
not I.T related or anything from our
area but then also talking about actual
projects and and it's not really
um for me it's never been about like
asking for permission for stuff it's
more of what is what is your uh what is
what are you trying to solve what is
your solution and then does this does
this make sense and let's ask the right
questions and then we can come up with a
solution to together
um
so it's trying to again build that trust
with which each each of your direct
reports so we oversee an engineering
team you want them to try to give you
what are the sources what are their
Solutions because you've got to weigh it
um
um you don't want to always like say
that oh this is where it is the only way
it's there's many ways it's just uh this
different
the different approaches that might take
different times and different things so
that's what you call the level it and
kind of talk it through
can I ask um what the structure of these
check-ins are now you you said uh random
topics but is it is it truly a agenda
list oh yeah no I have um a series uh
already set up so I'll again all my
direct reports uh are once a week
um I uh have overall
um management meetings that I set up
once a month and so yeah I just make
sure they're on the calendar already so
that I don't have to worry about making
those out to the back
about six two
very good a few more anonymous questions
I see Sally asked a question in the chat
get to that in a second
um what are your favorite resources for
keeping up with the industry and
self-studying
yeah so I I always look I saw uh it
depends on whatever I'm working out of
time so for a while I got really big
into visualization so I would look up
what are the best books about
visualizations what are the best authors
and I'll buy a bunch of books and read
those and then then the subject may turn
into um what about leaving a data area
so kind of the book they make so it
really depends on what subject is of
interest at that time or related to
whatever I'm working on
um so yeah it's uh I always I tend to go
to book wraps that's a hard copy uh
route but if I'm just like wanting to
know what's going on in Insurance Tech I
would just just hop on internet just
look up some articles or whatnot but in
general
um there's always books related
awesome Sally would you mind asking your
question live
hey yeah
hey Matthew I appreciate it today so as
a leader it is very important to see you
know those beneath you next to you
whatever see them grow and prosper same
as you and so as a leader how are you
facilitating that growth in your
teammates so you know personally and
professionally there's if you're not
growing then you're not becoming you
know better you know some people like me
I want to be a leader one day and but
also I want to be a better person
um so what are you better person that's
so big but you know what I mean
like what steps you have examples on how
you are helping that the growth in your
teammates
yep yep yeah so uh in a couple of
different ways so one is a little bit to
my older example is that
um I would like people to come with me
come up to me with the challenge but
also the solution at least the initial
scratch of the solution and let's work
the solution together and so that brings
the ability to one learn how to
communicate a little more to thinking
really about the on the challenge and
then defining a possible illusion or
even just the starting of that like what
what what can we start with and I'll
work from there
um and then uh and then also the uh
giving them bigger projects like I I
have projects that range from little
tiny ones that might be a couple of
months work or you have a couple year
ones so putting into different projects
and and I'm always again always very
open I always want my drug reporters to
tell me what do they want like I always
I think I've done this maybe like two or
three times a year maybe a little more
um like what are your goals um what do
you want to do where do you want to what
do you want to be in a couple of years
or what kind of challenges do you want
me to give to you to grow
and the other side of that is
um
um I we I have a budget for
um doing
um seminars or conferences or whatever
so I encourage those to go to those like
for example
um one of my direct reports went to
oxygen conference because
um they oversee our studio so uh it made
sense to be able to go through those so
I'm very much of encouragement to go to
those because I wanted to experience and
learn from others not everyone does
um
can uh knows all the different pieces
that are so you can do so it is a great
opportunity to talk to others about that
so that so I encourage to be using those
but I also encourage them to communicate
with others during that time yeah for
sure and so say you know these people
you're giving them a lot of all these
resources to do all these things
um but what if they all they know is I
wanna I wanna leave one day or you know
I want to be a c-suite executive one day
but they don't know really what they
want how are you able to bring that out
of them yeah so I I think it's getting
different opportunities right so if
there's a small project well why not
leave that project and uh we can sign
you a consultant to work with you
um and you can try to lead that
consultant to
um to see if it ends or be a more events
or or maybe you
um be part of a bigger project as a
resource for someone who can avoid the
other but what they think the solution
is what kind of keeping that open space
or their friendly space
um or just having
discussions maybe once or twice a week
where we just talk about the different
problems they're growing out there and
let's talk about different solutions
um so it's just very encouraging
encouraging of that open Communications
I think that's Keys otherwise yeah you
won't know
um what you want until you actually
start getting that feel for when you're
doing it exactly I I love that and I'm
gonna definitely take that with me
um just all those great ideas thank you
you're welcome
Matthew you've you've mentioned I think
twice now
um
managing Consultants or working with
Consultants as sort of uh
a way to develop leadership managerial
skills
it's a great perspective I honestly I I
haven't heard it before I'm curious if
like you're making that point sort of um
I'm assuming purposefully but like if
that's something that you've actually
thought through
yeah no
um so maybe I'm just Loosely always
saying I'll imagine working with
Consultants but I think just working
with any type of resources or employees
um but in general if you
if you want to be more of a I think it's
either or if you want to be a tech lead
or a manager you have to know how to
work with other people and um and so it
because in order to lead either people
person or as a tech person like you
really need to be able to communicate
with others teach others Mentor others
or whatnot you could just be a
individual contributor who is only
focused on I give one uh I'm giving a
task I'm gonna just do that very well
and that's that's totally fine but if
you want to start working with other
people like
um you need to find those opportunities
to be able to be doing that
um so yeah I might be using consultant
as loose very Loosely but I just need a
resource yeah
it's a great Insight um there's a
question in the chat from Ricardo if you
want to ask it live give you a few
seconds to hop in
oh my okay Robert can you hear me we can
hear you Ricardo welcome okay thank you
Robert for accepting my my question
Matthew how are you doing yeah good good
so Matthew yes you know I I was
listening to you and your experience as
a leader and you know I have been
exposed to you know the leadership
thoughts and I have read about it and in
general I have discovered a kind of two
different ways to live one is leadership
as a process where you have a team and
you teach them the procedures and you
develop you know procedures in order or
protocols in order to find Solutions and
the other one is either or no mutually
exclusive where you lead by example
where you develop virtues and those
virtues are transmitted as examples to
your team
so you know which one is the one that
you have found more important in your
personal experience
uh I think it'd be more of a hybrid or
two because
um
if you if you just focus on leading
through processes or procedures then
you're more of a technical leader in the
sense of I bill we defined the process
and he just follows us so you make that
you make the
um you define the wireframes Define all
that and they just followed it to me
that's a little more of a technical
leader but then other side of that
um
you need to be able to also communicate
and I think this is where it gets you to
more of the manager type of leader or
the leader um Android managers
um because you got to communicate
outside of your team right so
um you might be leading your own team
you might be doing on that but you can't
get from there to outside of your team
so other managers other leaders then
you're you're going to be kind of stuck
so it's it's
um
I I had to do both of those at the same
time so I can lead my own team create
processes create some examples but then
I also need to communicate that this is
what we've been doing to Direct Express
[Music]
foreign
I was yes and no I mean it's I I'm sorry
just just to push a little bit no
apologies okay fine that's your fault
okay Matthew I just I was so I was
reading it on the comments and I think
that this idea kind of resonates with me
managers do things right leaders do the
right things
so that's that's kind of I was heading
to
so you know when you do to do the right
things for your team so so how that goes
in starting from you
oh okay so you're managing people you
are interacting with other people but
that forces you if you want to lead them
to to do the right thing to them even if
that's painful
how that question is
um at least about my understanding so
you're saying that what what are the
ways that I'm leading that will benefit
the team uh what style of leadership I'm
doing to benefit the team yes I think
that is a good way to put okay so uh so
I actually do a mixture of all those
right so
um I if if I'm if I'm looking at or
reviewing a um a uh a group and I see
that maybe there's any gaps or anything
that can't be improved on well I'll work
with that team to see what are the
processes we can put in place that can
actually solve that if there's a gap
this is a process Gap or is this
something that
um or maybe it's just a communication
gap then that's a little different
um but then when it comes to a new area
or something I'm trying to bring in then
I might build that um process or I might
build a example of what that's going to
look like so say for example um if I
want to build a um a tiny dashboard
um someone has to build it first to
actually it's uh to actually give a
demonstration on what it's like so I
might put together a simple example of
Australian dashboard and be able to
explain like why is it beneficial why is
that it's just like a quick minimum MVP
of that
um so I kind of do a mixture of all
those
thank you
uh there's a slido question what are
some recent developments in the data
services Tech platform space that you're
excited about such as database Tech
streaming real-time services mlops
I think a lot what's exciting and we
haven't got a chance to really spend too
much time on it but is the idea of the
at least the
interface to build shining apps without
code meaning that you can create the UI
generator because that's actually
um something that I was trying to do a
couple years back
um um I'll build a code base that would
do that
um and I got pretty far on it but then
things shifted
um and then I still have to stop that
project and then but then seeing that
I'm like wow this is actually really
nice better than what I was doing and
then
um but yeah so that is I think opening a
door for new things to happen and so I'm
excited to see what is going to come
from that so we haven't got a chance to
really dig into that
um yeah but that's something we want to
dig into and I have a feeling it's going
to open up more users
just
there's a question uh an anonymous
question that probably warrants it's its
own uh full session but let's see if we
can uh
give a good concise answer
um it's essentially how do I jump into
Tech I have zero experience but I'm
interested what approach and mindset
should a person be in
so I think it really depends on what
you're doing now
so
um one of the things
when I first started working
um so I was in the split team one was
focused on modeling and other one as
well as Ferraro so and they're very
split you know since that
um it was only the output of the
modeling so maybe reports are well now
they're actually used by the actuary the
network code part
so I tried to then during my regular
work I find some things that may be
inefficient or maybe it can be improved
on and so I then brought my knowledge
and coding into that space take all that
as a side project and create some
process that might be simplified and so
um so I learned everything from the
ground up from that and and then not one
include my my own skill set but then two
it uh it
demonstrated to management or to other
other individuals of here's the
potential of using Tech
and to press a little bit um more so
like the types of roles that are let's
call it them like Tech adjacent like
business analyst comes to mind uh
curious if you have any any thoughts
there so like in the world of tech but
not quite uh you know a programming or
Tech role
yeah so uh probably an analyst of some
sorts without a time I've saved my title
with the actual analyst
um but yeah it's analysts have a role
right so you you are in the weeds of
things um an actual business process
um you find
um areas or challenges that could be
improved upon and then you take on that
injury more engineering type of mindset
of let me let me see if we can come up
with a solution using Code might not
think of the whole thing uh from end to
end or I might not think of it was the
actual impact to the whole business but
just in my little little piece of work
let me see if I can try and improve on
it
um so yeah I think it's
um uh easy as is when you're an analyst
I think you have low low more uh you're
very close to everything without
um and maybe having more of the
bandwidth to be able to do some these
side projects
very good and we're approaching the top
of the hour I think um
maybe let's cap the session off with um
a question of I think I think most of
um the people who attend to hang out
would consider themselves like firmly in
the data science space correct me if I'm
wrong in the uh Zoom shot I actually
don't know um but that's I think that's
our our running assumption and Matthew
you have the privilege of sort of being
in both both data science and now I.T
oriented if you could give a tip or
multiple tips to data scientists working
with it what would that be
um being very forthcoming on what you're
what are all the things that you can
want to do right so it's not as simple
as saying I want a platform to be
available for data scientism for myself
it's more of what are what are you
really trying to accomplish without
platform because it might be modeling it
might be all that and it's a little bit
more complicated than I think just
saying that I want a platform and so if
you open those channels of communication
get the support of
um upper management and I.T uh and of
course your own business side
um that's what you can accomplish those
things if you don't have the support of
the I.T side or manager on either side
um you're going to be formal pretty fast
so you really need to make sure that
Communication channel is there and if
you're if you're not that person that is
ready to take that on and it sends out
how to make to make it open channel one
now make sure to find that person
because you it is a lot of
communications
okay
I think when I uh just heard you say was
do everything Rogue don't bring it
so if uh people would want to get in
touch with you uh how can they do that
yeah LinkedIn is probably the easiest
way so I think my LinkedIn is somewhere
um or something so that's probably the
best way to get a hold of me
um email's pretty tough I'll pop that in
the chat well
as always thank you everyone for your
participation and Matthew thank you uh
awesome insights